tell us about your character Meredith
crown well I work in a grain elevator
and I live in a small town and i'm in
love with the dennis quaid hair here let
me ask you this do you have to like your
character as a person to be able to play
it I know she has an interesting side to
her and there's some interesting things
do you have to like her or can you
understand who she is and still be able
to play her as a fully fleshed-out
person I mean I think you sort of have
to like her in a way yeah you have to
find a way to like or even if the
behaviors questionable you do have to
really I think you do yeah do you end
last question here do you go into a back
story about who she would be and why she
would be who she is and what shaped her
living in the small town for sure yeah
max Oriole yeah yeah well thank you very
much appreciated